Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Parto da questa slide,
che appunto rappresenta
questo evento sorprendente anche per me
della presentazione
da parte di Steve Jobs,
nell'evento di presentazione
di iPad 2, di una app
realizzata in Italia da Applix
e sviluppata da Mondadori.
Il fatto che l'imperatore
dell'impero digitale
sia andato ai confini dell'impero
-- sapete che non siamo
tra i primi nel mondo nel digitale --
a prendere l'app
di qualche sperduto suddito
e l'abbia presentata
come emblema dello sviluppo
del suo futuro prodotto è sorprendente.
Mi sono sorpreso
e ho cercato di capire perché.
Vediamo cosa dice:
SJ: Le cose che la gente
sta realizzando sono fantastiche.
Stanno sfruttando quest'incredible,
magica interfaccia utente,
su una tavola molto
più grande con più risorse.
R.C: Esattamente: in sostanza, dice
che ci sono interfacce sorpredenti.
In particolare ce n'è una
che allarga lo schermo di iPad.
In effetti la nostra tecnologia,
sviluppata in Italia,
modifica il paradigma di utilizzo di iPad
e questo probabilmente ha sopreso Jobs
che, in qualche modo,
ha voluto stigmatizzare
un'evoluzione verso la realtà aumentata
di iPad che era in essere.
Questa tecnologia si chiama BubbleViewer
e permette di costruire una sorta
di bolla virtuale attorno a noi.
Questa è la sua caratteristica:
è molto semplice,
ci permette di vedere, ad esempio,
il Colosseo come era e come è.
Adesso ne vediamo alcune applicazioni.
Ecco vediamo appunto la scena
che ho appena fatto vedere.
in cui la ricostruzione del Colosseo
viaggia nel tempo.
La caratteristica fondamentale
del BubbleViewer
è il fatto che crea diversi mondi digitali
in una bolla virtuale attorno all'utente.
Lo schermo diventa
una sorta di telescopio,
ed in questo caso vediamo una scena
di Pompei in un mondo virtuale,
la Casa del Fauno in questo Caso,
oppure questo dipinto
che diventa tridimensionale.
Una nuova esperienza del territorio,
come abbiamo visto,
che ci permette di avere
un'esperienza coinvolgente,
di scoprire l'invisibile, ad esempio
il Mausoleo di Adriano
di fronte a Castel S.Angelo,
oppure applicazioni industriali
utilizzabili in diversi campi.
Una finestra aperta
su infiniti mondi digitali,
in questo caso abbiamo il Circo Massimo
di cui possiamo vedere
il presente ed il passato.
La caratteristica fondamentale
di BubbleViewer
è questa sua relazione col corpo.
Questo suo avere grazie alla bussola
digitale, all'acceleromentro e al GPS
la possibilità di creare
un mondo attorno a noi.
Andiamo oltre su questa domanda:
cosa implica questo scenario,
che è abbastanza chiaro, penso, evidente
a tutti nella sua immediatezza.
Che il post-PC, questa nuova era
aperta da Steve Jobs,
da lui denominata,
definisce dei nuovi device
che sono protesi della mente e dei sensi.
Ciò che noi dobbiamo fare come designer
-- io sono un designer digitale --
a questo punto è progettare
delle esperienze multisensoriali
che si praticano in mondi digitali,
o in mondi misti tra reali e digitali.
Questo scenario è abbastanza
chiaro da questo schema.
Steve Jobs aveva inventato, o
per lo meno aveva imposto sul mercato
la metafora della scrivania con Macintosh,
in cui la condizione dell'uomo
era molto semplice:
si era seduti, come in un ufficio,
e si aveva di fronte uno schermo fisso.
L'interazione fisica era molto limitata,
era la tastiera e il mouse.
Quello che sta succedendo, grazie
ai nuovi device imposti da Jobs,
è che, in pratica, si moltiplicano i
contesti di rapporto col mondo digitale.
Prima in fondo, avevamo di fronte
degli oggetti simili
a quelli della scrivania
e quindi avevamo un cestino, dei fogli
di carta, delle cartelle.
Adesso abbiamo di fronte
cose completamente diverse.
Semplicemente perché
la finestra sul mondo digitale
non è più fissa, non è più un ufficio,
ma è ovunque.
Ovviamente si apre uno scenario
estremamente interessante
per il design ed anche
dal punto di vista antropologico.
In sostanza l'uomo si alza,
si alza da seduto,
va in piedi, va in auto, si può sdraiare,
può leggere finalmente:
non avevo mai letto libri sul PC
- in realtà è un problema
di spina dorsale, non tecnologico.
Può giocare, muoversi,
interagire con le mani.
Può consultare il mondo
in qualunque momento
e può interagire con una realtà,
con dei filtri, dei nuovi visori.
La cinestesia, l'intelligenza motoria,
è praticamente
l'elemento nuovo del design.
La cinestesia è quella
forma di intelligenza
che viene attuata quando
si impara ad andare in bicicletta.
Il bambino non sa andare in bicicletta,
c'è un apprendimento motorio
e poi una memoria cinestetica
che gli permette poi di saper sempre
andare in bicicletta,
quindi è una forma di intelligenza
come quella logica, quella visiva.
Questa forma di intelligenza
entra nel mondo digitale.
Diventa protagonista in questo scenario.
Vediamo in quali contesti,
facciamo degli esempi concreti.
Gli ultimi successi nei videogiochi
sono di carattere cinestetico.
Kinect, kinesti, cinestesia, movimento.
Sostanzialmente il corpo
entra nel digitale,
interagisce con questo mondo
con un oggetto,
o addirittura con le mani stesse.
L'auto, sta cambiando.
Noi stiamo lavorando
su di un progetto europeo
che si occupa di augmented driving,
cioè di relazione,
di utilizzo delle tecnologie
di realtà aumentata nell'auto.
Attenzione: non siamo
in ufficio, siamo in auto,
siamo in un contesto pericoloso
come in una fabbrica,
come in una fonderia, possiamo ammazzarci.
Quindi il designer
ha prima di tutto il compito
di controllare la mia cinestesia:
devo essere controllato,
devo avere come priorità
lo sguardo verso la strada
e quello che sta succedendo.
In realtà la stessa realtà aumentata
deve capire
se ci sono delle macchine, dei pedoni,
dei cartelli che mi danno dei segnali.
Ma io non posso interagire.
Insomma, ogni contesto d'uso
deve creare un'experience precisa,
che a volte determina
la sopravvivenza stessa dell'uomo.
In certi casi, sappiamo bene
che l'utilizzo
di device mobili in movimento
può causare degli incidenti.
Il designer deve occuparsi
anche di questo.
Gli smartphone.
Qui siamo di fronte alla sfida chiave
e al grande episodio di iPhone,
che ha introdotto, appunto, con uno
strumento di massa di successo
l'utilizzo di Internet
e del mondo digitale
in uno strumento
che prima era solo vocale.
Mentre avevamo il telefonino
potevamo camminare, perché parlavamo.
Se invece interagiamo
dobbiamo fermarci,
altrimenti ci schiantiamo,
come quando siamo in macchina.
In generale va studiata
quest'opportunità enorme.
Teniamo conto che il passaggio
al mondo digitale nei telefonini
sposterà in 3-4 anni tutti gli italiani
verso una protesi di grande potenza
molto più potente della voce
che ci permetterà di avere un enorme
patrimonio di informazioni disponibili
in ogni momento,
addirittura un'opportunità
per accrescere l'intelligenza,
per fare l'Italia stessa più smart.
Smartphone e tablet
come rivoluzione ergonomica:
la cinestesia fondamentale applicata
da Jobs nell'iPhone è stato il touch.
Una serie di brevetti che descrivono
i movimenti delle dita.
Perché le dita?
È stata un'altra chiave del successo
perché il touch abbassa le barriere.
Se riflettiamo bene, le mani
- come la bocca e come gli occhi,
sono uno degli elementi chiave
con cui il pensiero opera nel mondo.
Sopratutto nell'arte,
perché con le mani facciamo,
dipingiamo, facciamo musica,
l'abbiamo visto prima.
Le mani sono uno strumento fondamentale,
perché il pensiero
diventi concreto nel mondo.
A questo punto osserviamo alcune
loro applicazioni al mondo dell'arte.
Queste sono altre esperienze
che abbiamo sviluppato,
sempre di carattere cinestetico
ma orientate all'utilizzo delle dita.
In queste opere
che abbiamo creato con Mondadori,
in cui vediamo per esempio
oggetti manipolabili
di ogni tipo, che possono
essere appunto girati
e si può interagire
come se fossero oggetti reali.
Qui, addirittura, con le dita
coloriamo una statua
e recuperiamo i colori originali
delle opere d'arte romane
che erano, come sapete, colorate.
Oppure possiamo
trasformare delle opere d'arte
per analizzarle, per entrare in esse,
per renderle dinamiche.
Sempre con l'uso delle mani,
delle dita che esplorano questo mondo
come per esempio la zona del Colosseo
che viene trasformata
da Nerone nella Domus Aurea
e poi diventa l'Anfiteatro Flavio.
Possiamo viaggiare nel tempo
velocemente con le dita,
possiamo percorrere infiniti scenari
che vengono a nostra disposizione,
abbiamo un mondo in mano.
Un'ulteriore riflessione
su questo scenario.
Io sono convinto
che ci sia qualcosa di inquietante,
o molti di voi percepiscono qualcosa
di inquietante in questo scenario,
in quanto, da un certo punto di vista,
questa presenza di mondi virtuali
che abbiamo visto in film come Matrix
creano una serie di inquietudini,
in quanto si considera questo aspetto
estremamente inumano.
Io credo che non sia così.
Riprendendo un tema antropologico,
circa 35.000 anni fa,
in realtà Homo Sapiens
si distingue in modo chiaro
grazie ad alcune opere d'arte
che sono sostanzialmente delle Bubble.
Andiamo a Lascaux, andiamo a vedere
i dipinti primitivi paleolitici di Lascaux
e siamo sostanzialmente in una Bubble,
che probabilmente era multisensoriale
perché era animata da riti.
Quindi il mondo immersivo
è antico come l'uomo.
Lo vediamo anche a Padova, nella Cappella
degli Scrovegni di Giotto,
lo vediamo nella Cappella Sistina
di Michelangelo.
Entriamo e siamo immersi in una Bubble,
siamo immersi in un mondo virtuale.
Stiamo lavorando su questa direzione,
stiamo cercando di capire come l'arte
-che, appunto, è una
disciplina multisensoriale-
possa entrare in questo scenario
e avere un ruolo,
perché se l'arte non entra nel digitale,
a cosa serve il digitale?
Se il pensiero non diventa più intenso,
a cosa serve, a fare quattro
chiacchere su facebook?
Il problema è anche questo,
il problema è una sfida
in cui la cultura deve
intraprendere percorsi nuovi,
ne vediamo uno proprio
dedicato alle cattedrali.
Questa è una cattedrale virtuale
che rappresenta
un nuovo progetto che stiamo sviluppando
che è un libro, non è una cattedrale;
è la Bibbia stessa multisensoriale.
D'altra parte questo lo sono
sempre state, le cattedrali.
Sono sacre rappresentazioni
della Sacra Scrittura.
La Genesi sul pavimento la vediamo
in molte chiese, come l'Apocalisse sopra.
La pittura, la musica,
la scultura, l'architettura
convergono su questo scenario.
L'ipotesi è quella di cominciare a pensare
un'arte multisensoriale
per l'era digitale;
un'arte che coinvolga i sensi, che
comunque costruisca degli ambienti
che non sono inumani,
sono profondamente umani
e anche legati al nostro passato.
La sfida che ci si propone oggi
è quella, in realtà,
di qualcosa di molto più modesto
di una cattedrale:
è il salotto in cui tutti le sere
ci riposiamo e guardiamo la televisione.
Il media dominante,
in realtà, di questi anni,
non è stato il computer,
è stata la televisione.
La maggiore rivoluzione non sarà
la rivoluzione che modifica il PC,
ma la rivoluzione che modificherà
la televisione dal punto di vista sociale.
È questo lo scenario
più affascinante e più imminente,
perché accadrà tra pochissimo.
Si stanno sperimentando nuove forme
di interazione vocali con il televisore,
nuove forme di interazioni
gestuali, ovviamente,
utilizzando tecnologie
tra l'altro già disponibili.
Il problema è pensare ad una rivoluzione
che non sia solo ergonomica
e tecnologica, ma sociale e politica.
Questa è la sfida che
si pone, in generale,
per dare lavoro, per creare
una forte innovazione
che sposti il nostro PIL dal 2% al 7%
e dia lavoro ai giovani,
perché è questo lo scenario
in cui si creeranno
i posti di lavoro,
sopratutto per i giovani.
Dobbiamo avere il coraggio, quindi,
di intraprendere questa strada
e di modificare la nostra relazione
con contesti consolidati,
che devono essere modificati proprio
per aprire nuove opportunità,
sopratutto ai giovani.
Quindi, quello che io vorrei
in qualche modo indicare
come un percorso che ritengo interessante
è quello che conduce verso
un design italiano nel mondo digitale.
Consideriamo che, in realtà,
noi come italiani da secoli
progettiamo oggetti fisici
che possono essere opere d'arte,
ci siamo distinti per questo.
Negli ultimi decenni
è nata questa disciplina,
in cui siamo diventati leader nel mondo
che ha progettato di tutto,
certamente comunque oggetti fisici.
Quello che si prospetta nel nuovo secolo
è condurre questa esperienza
in cui c'è uno stile di vita
che tutti ci invidiano, anche,
nell'experience digitale.
Perché l'experience digitale
è uno scenario troppo importante,
perché sia trascurato.
Nel senso che è più importante che
progettare una sedia, un divano o un'auto.
In realtà, qui c'è in gioco di più
ed in questo gioco noi
possiamo giocare, anche noi.
Forse anche con un ruolo importante.
Arrivederci.
(applausi)